hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes the finest
entertainment on earth tosses it into a
pit and makes it fight for supremacy i'm
your host mark ellis and while i am
super attractive on camera today's
episode will be all about those geniuses
who stand on the other side of the lens
some call them shot callers others refer
to them as the folks that yell action
but they're best known by the
all-encompassing moniker directors
that's right it's a scintillating
cinematic slugfest starring scorsese and
spielberg when you think directors does
anyone else come to mind before those
two fellas
if you are marty or steven and i feel
fine calling them that because they're
not here but if they come on the set i
would instantly refer to them as doctor
or maestro or father whatever the hell
they want anyway m dog and senor
spielberg both refer to brian de palma
as the filmmaker but everyone else on
earth would probably list these two as
the greatest of anyone who ever did that
weird framing thing with their hands i'm
sure with that
in one corner you have martin scorsese
maker of gangster pictures gritty boxing
intensives and a bunch of other stuff
with robert de niro in the other corner
it's steven spielberg the helmer of
alien movies swashbuckling adventures
and a bunch of other stuff involving
diabolical prehistoric animals your two
competitors today are good pals they've
collabed on each other's projects from
time to time and both have been in the
same room with george lucas i shouldn't
use my name but today only one will
emerge from the shark-infested waters of
versus and be honored as a maid man i
hope it goes better for them than it did
for joe pesci you worry too much dude
everything is beautiful there's nothing
to worry about here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three heroes round four
villains and then we'll do a wild card
round that steven spielberg hopes will
involve the use of giant boulders in
film i'm gonna continue to do things the
way i think they should be done or maybe
it'll favor which director does that
hyper close up zoom the best don't punch
in on me i don't want the audience to
see how much makeup i actually use it
looks good from this distance but you
get any closer you'll realize i look
like cesar romero as the joker i'm funny
how i mean funny like i'm a clown i am
usual either one of these directors ever
make a uh batman
no but spielberg worked with a young
christian bale on empire of the sun and
scorsese did the departed with jack
nicholson who once upon a time murdered
bruce wayne's parents something maybe
happened to him
but enough about comic book movies it's
high time for a duel between two of the
goodest fellas that ever walked onto a
movie set let's get it on
or i guess action
round one box office
well you saw what the first four rounds
are and so you're assuming that mr
blockbuster steven spielberg is gonna
win this box office round going away and
then scorsese will probably take the
tomato meter around well not so fast
you don't i'm sorry i will be showcasing
my incredible delivery from time to time
just in case either star maker is
watching this program come on marty i
can be your next leo stephen do you need
a younger indiana jones
don't laugh
this ain't reality tv i will allow
martin scorsese to open the festivities
here just to see if he'll be any
competition to the guy that made you
know jurassic park there's no doubt our
attractions will drive kids out of their
minds and lo and behold martin scorsese
the auteur of auteurs has some pretty
big hits on his resume how's 389 million
dollars sound that's good for me that
was the worldwide total for the wolf of
wall street and that stands as the
hugest hit on marty's resume so far it
also is only pictured across the 300
million dollar mark but shutter island
got oh so close with a 299 million
dollar total haul you know i've built
something valuable here and valuable
things have a way of being misunderstood
in their own time the departed also got
close with 289 million and the aviator
flew past the 200 million dollar line as
well and hugo an underrated scorsese
love letter to the history of film and
giant clocks made an impressive 180
million dollars
thank you so the guys made tons of bread
for the studios but curiously it's his
best known works that struggled to even
crack 50 million dollars taxi driver
didn't raging bull couldn't i could have
been a contender and goodfellas even
came up short but evened it out after
you know collecting the insurance money
all right all right
i know the rest so for every hit like
casino which did make over 100 million
dollars you have a the king of comedy
which is excellent but only grows 2.5
million dollars that's barely enough to
pay for jerry lewis's ransom it's
terrific i'm having a blast recounting
the hits from marty and i'm honestly
impressed at how much dough his films
have collect wait what's that you hear
something uh oh i just saw my glass of
water start rippling steven spielberg
doesn't want to be fed steven spielberg
wants to hunt must go faster
and boy does he have his sights set on
butts in seats at movie theaters martin
scorsese's total box office for all of
his films worldwide is 2.15 billion
dollars jurassic park made half that all
by itself in 1993 the sequel added
another 618 million dollars and after
the over 400 million dollars generated
by a certain man-eating shark we have
matched the great scorsese
now this is fine art and it's not all
about commerce but don't tell that to
the fortunate gory hound named indiana
jones dude has made three and a half
good movies to date drop dead and those
films have totaled over 1.9 billion
dollars worldwide ready player one made
579 million dollars mostly thanks to van
halen's jump playing in the opening
sequence world of worlds did 606 million
dollars and it feels like i'm missing an
alien movie here can you say e.t oh
right everyone's favorite beer chugging
extraterrestrial the cleverly named e.t
extraterrestrial
that slimy botanist generated a shade
under 800 million dollars back in 1982.
and can we all now admit that he might
have been a spy for the war of the
worlds folk to come on down here to turn
us into intestinal spaghetti give me a
break speaking of spies bridge of spies
catch me if you can the terminal and
saving private ryan all star tom hanks
who himself enjoys crushing at the
cineplex and they combined for almost
1.5 billion all by themselves well of
course when you put it that way it
appears marty's about to say uncle in
this round but for funsies let's see how
the averages stack up i will not get
drawn into another financial debate with
you scorsese films averaged 94 million
dollars per flick worldwide which is
impressive when you think about his
smaller films that barely saw a movie
theater before they were turned into
oscar screeners but steven reigns
supreme here as well earning an average
of 330 million dollars every time one of
his films is released by a very happy
studio no wonder that guy keeps getting
work fortune and glory kid
fortune and glory
it's an easy round one win for spielberg
but scorsese showed me some fight in a
phase no one expected him to compete in
he'll need to gather all of his inner
jake lamotta strength to get a win today
and his fortunes may be looking up as we
head to
round two tomato meter slash audience
score oh that's a downright cocky marty
throwing into this round the glasses are
on the eyebrows are bushy and he has
every right to feel confident this round
is won by whichever filmmaker wooed the
critics and hit it big with audiences
that audience score is something i'm
very curious to investigate because
spielberg is known for his big crowd
pleasers but scorsese has made some of
the most endlessly rewatchable films
this side of shawshank
yeah maybe
but first we roll out the red carpet for
the critics on the tomato meter don't
you threaten me
martin lives up to his reputation here
as he has 10 films that earned a 90 or
above in the veggie patch 11 if you
include his wonderful 2019 bob dylan
documentary i will certainly count the
last waltz the film that followed the
band and is still the standard bearer
for music docs what band was it the band
who's on first what's on second the name
of the band is the band that's not funny
that was great anyway that's at 98
percent the irishman is 95
raging bull 94 and the trio of mean
streets taxi driver god this guy makes
good movies and goodfellas are all fresh
at 96 percent movies like the aviator
and the age of innocents are most good
in the 80 range movies like the wolf of
wall street and casino are in the 70s
and the experience known as shutter
island is at 68
which begs the question does this guy
have any rotten movies on his entire
resume
yep
one i never asked my clients to judge me
on my winners
i asked them to judge me on my losers
because i have so few
one movie do you want to guess
it involves a certain city
twice new york new york it's the black
sheep of this crew but it still competes
with a 58
this guy's really good with the camera
especially when that camera is inside a
prison filming mobsters cook a classic
italian feast who wants olive garden
he's out of his mind steven spielberg is
very impressed with his pal i'm sure but
he's not exactly shaken in his boots he
also has 10 fresh films that surpass 90
11 if you count west side story we
should but as of this taping it's still
being reviewed i think the kids are
going to like it though it might catch
me if you can which is 96 percent but
the overall breadwinner for steven is
still e.t
at 99
that's right you little naked weirdo 99
celebrate with your favorite brew of
course
jaws and schindler's list are at 98
raiders of the lost ark is 95
close encounters of the mashed potato
kind is 94
saving private ride is 93 and some
dinosaur flick is 92 percent no wonder
we keep buying tickets to spielberg
movies they're like really good i know
it's a hot take but bear with me thanks
thank you right thank reit reed and
thank you scorsese has his buddy beat by
the law of averages on the tomato meter
84 for him 80 for spielberg oh if only
he didn't make hook you must be joking
look i know so many people swear by that
movie it's 29 on the matroday tomato you
lose crude rude bag of pre-chewed food
dude
so martin's got the edge but not enough
to call this round just yet so we turned
it over to the audience score and one
would think steven spielberg can seize
momentum
thank god
on that metric the color purple and
empire of the sun improve upon their
tomato meter freshness by getting into
the 90s 94 for purple 90 for empire oh
and jaws is still right there at 90
percent and indiana jones in the last
crusade juniors its way to a 94
all told his audience score average per
film is 76
which sounds odd and that puzzle is
solved because apparently audiences
didn't like waiting for tom cruise to
not really save the world in war of the
worlds that's his lowest film on the
audience score metric landing at 42
percent even
did better at 48
and you remember how much we all love dt
well it's only 72 on the audience score
were you rooting for the government
i don't know what they've got there
scorsese can taste that win like i can
taste that pasta from peshe's mom and
good boys on their way to bury billy
bats
thank you that film is the highest for
martin scorsese on the audience score by
the by 97 percent followed by an
approved casino for at 93 percent and
they departed at 94 percent remember
health scorsese only had one rotten film
in the tomato meter well the same thing
is true for the audience score you want
to guess what it is it's a new york one
but no damage done his overall per film
average for the audience score is 81
and once again he tops spielberg which
means marty earns his first point of the
day he wins round two and we got us a
tight game one to one he chose
poorly round three heroes
so we're tied and now we have not one
but two rounds to examine the intense
characterizations brought to magnificent
life thanks to the direction of master
class instructors martin scorsese i
think steven spielberg's on there too
okay so steven spielberg won the box
office round by the way i haven't gotten
an apology yet for that and those
audiences like to cheer for a hero but
scorsese took on the tomato meat around
and villains make for more complex
character studies what i'm saying is
that both of these gents have a shot
right here
right now but the advantage has to start
with spielberg because of that sexy
archaeologist guy you wait your turn sam
neil i'm referring to indiana jones
steven and his pal george lucas dreamt
up this character while on one of their
patented hey i just set a new box office
record let's get out of dodge vacations
to hawaii
indy is a hero through and through but a
more human one than first meets the eye
he'll save the day for sure but along
the way he'll make mistakes with women i
don't like fast women paul pray to his
impulses and probably end up tied back
to back with his old man i'm sorry you
think so but being a cool guy hero is
easy when you're played by harrison ford
just look at him walking down the stairs
in the white talks at the beginning of
temple of doom that kid's is a movie
star i'm totally unappreciated in my
time but it's an even bigger
accomplishment to have achieved so many
iconic moments with said alistar and
steven spielberg gave us such classic
sequences as the boulder drop the mine
shaft race the tank spread the opening
of the ark of the covenant and a
centuries-old knight who is so happy to
finally have house guests remind me to
thank john for a lovely weekend add in
folks like tom hanks is hand ready and
catch me if you can tom hanks is james
donovan and bridges spies and tom hanks
is captain john miller in saving private
ryan and you get a whole lot of hanks
and a bushel of fresh heroes but if
hanks has spielberg's heroic muse maybe
scorsese has one that tends towards the
good side of the tracks de niro
yeah maybe we'll save him for the next
round you leave him out of this he's
often enough the man hasn't been able to
digest a decent meal in six weeks
although we are sometimes rooting for
him against our better judgment in films
like casino how about leonardo dicaprio
excellent fine fine
okay yes the departed he's undercover
looking for moles rats and sweet mob
mustaches he may fall victim to the dark
side of life more than to buy the book
mark wahlberg and martin sheen but i
will give him credit for being a hero
and he's also a good guy in shutter
island if you left early mark ruffalo
was certainly an actual goodie two shoes
in that so look we have some competition
here you're telling me sonny boy we're
also rooting for scorsese characters
like hugo and insane nick cage and
bringing out the dead and
the rolling stones anyone shine a light
is great speaking of light good and
heroes indiana jones rules eric bonne
and munich is great and tin tin is also
a definite winner but scorsese has the
ultimate ace remember his movie the last
temptation of christ i've talked too
much already silence is better yeah
jesus is in that so yeah martin scorsese
knows a thing or two about making us
root for someone however spielberg just
has too much volume for marty in this
round i'm going to call jaws a draw
because as much as i love quint hooper
and brody for what they did for amity
island jaws can also be considered a
hero to shark kind i don't know what it
was between the sharks and the brody
family but i do know all the other great
whites women out there still talk about
bruce with dear reference see the lack
of humility before nature that's being
displayed here sometimes much like ray
leota's henry hill and goodfellas the
star attraction can be good bad he
didn't run out as friends that's good
but he also killed a bunch of people and
was a horrible husband to a hero like
lorraine bronco keep out of it you don't
know how i feel but when he
pistol-whipped karen's neighbor that was
well earned i'm putting that check in
the hero column this is all in your mind
but this sort of hero kind of villain
thing isn't just a martin scorsese card
to play how about the t-rex in jurassic
park scary as hell killed a few folks
but also saved us from cunning
velociraptors and is partly responsible
for why we got more star wars movies
thanks roberta that's her name
i could go on and on about the
fantastical heroes spielberg has given
us like the bfg or peter pan but i can
also focus on more real important films
like schindler's list and also folks
like sync jamon hunson's character in
amistad or selly played by whoopi
goldberg in the color purple i want to
say steven spielberg discovered whoopi
during one of her sets in the belly room
of the world famous comedy store i'll be
downstairs in the original room later on
tonight you're making a big spectacle of
yourself so this round might have been
slightly weighted towards a filmmaker
like steven spielberg
so much so that i might put his
non-human heroes up against scorsese's
entire catalog war horse e.t
one of the cars from duel the list could
go on and on in this round now again
i'll reiterate martin scorsese has jesus
christ on his side but stephen has abe
lincoln and lots of tom cruise and the
washington post folks that expose
political cover-ups right into vietnam
so what would jesus do
probably give the point to spielberg and
then ask me to stop invoking his name
during a trivial match of cinematic
combat point taken spielberg by the way
gets the point and is back on top two to
one you have chosen
wisely
round four villains
if we know spielberg for his heroes we
certainly know scorsese for his villains
but remember if stevie pulls out a win
in this round he's gonna win the whole
match and he's bringing the lumber
because he has in his corner from the
classic jaws you know him you love him
he's the best villain in the movie mayor
larry vaughn the beaches are open and
people are having a wonderful time the
worst mayor in amity history sold the
safety of his beachgoers just to make a
few bucks during 4th of july that kids
is the real bad guy please
the shark was just hungry and didn't
want intruders in his house you want to
go swimming sure it'll cost you a leg
and you know a kid or two but even
though murray hamilton's may or may be
in jaws i can at least say he meant well
the dude's a buffoon but i'd rather vote
for him than say travis bickle bickle is
the hero of his own story but he's a
complicated fellow and the danger he
presents to society can certainly be
interpreted as villain-like robert de
niro continued that trend as rupert
pumpkin in the king of comedy when he
kidnaps a popular tv host in order to
forge ahead in his own career really
don't get any ideas loyal fans
although it would be kind of fun to have
somebody tie me up in a chair indiana
jones style while you host the show try
it see how easy it is you mean i have
your permission speaking of indiana
jones nazis i hate these guys and in
large part because they're villains
regardless of whether it's the more
cartoonish ones from the indie flicks or
the herring real life versions in
schindler's list they leave an
impression on us long after the film has
ended as for mr de niro he'd go on to
star in goodfellas casino and the
irishman as a mobster type we follow his
storylines we can easily fall into the
trap of rooting for him but it's because
that trap is so well concealed we want
to be one of the cool kids and for all
their illegal activities like killing
excuse me painting houses folks like de
niro and joe pesci seem to have so much
fun doing it it's intoxicating for the
audience don't make me be a bad guy come
on but in case you had any questions as
to whether bobby could play a straight
up baddie in a martin scorsese film
might introduce you to max from cape
fear he's awful no matter what the
circumstance biting appendages off
impersonating a teacher and he commits
the worst crime of all smoking a cigar
in a movie theater
trivia time in that famous scene where
max is laughing maniacally in the back
of the theater what movie is everyone
watching you guessed it problem child
which is currently zero percent on the
tomato meter when we take a gander over
at steven spielberg's resume we do see a
fair amount of scary creatures aliens
and fish but are they straight-up
villains or are they maybe just a
reflection of humanity's own foibles
again we went into the shark's house and
paid for it and we created the dinosaurs
in jurassic park so what did we expect
them to not dinosaur maybe mankind is
the real villain of steven spielberg's
films oh there it is
and yes i use the term mankind as
all-encompassing but let's be real it's
usually men that are doing this crap on
behalf of all of us i'm sorry ladies we
do not deserve you
but dr elsa schneider is a nazi so you
know is that what you think of me
rudolph abel and frank abbotnail are two
great examples of how spielberg like
scorsese can make multi-faceted villains
that are intriguing we're enamored with
mark rylance's oscar-winning turn as
soviet spy abel and we straight up root
for dicaprio's abignale as he charmingly
lies his way around the world but mark
scorsese has built an entire career as
an expert storyteller that focuses on
the dark nature of humanity it's a
chicken egg conundrum as to whether the
mean streets of a metropolis like new
york create these monsters or if it's
the evil underbelly of the human
condition that makes city life so gritty
regardless of whether it's jack
nicholson and the departed daniel day
lewis and gangs of new york or anyone in
the irishman they're all interesting
character studies and their
three-dimensional nature makes them so
relatable that we find ourselves
invested in their stories even as we
know they'll eventually get a
comeuppance spielberg has some all-time
great baddies to his credit but no one
zooms in on what makes a villain tick
like scorsese he gets to win in round
four and lo and behold we're tied going
into the final round for the life of me
i i can't figure out why
it's time for the wild card round legacy
to be fair both marty and steven have
nothing to worry about when it comes to
their lasting imprint on cinema they
both changed the game and furthered the
art time and time again they could make
nothing but problem child sequels for
the next two decades and we'd still hail
them as possibly the two best directors
to ever pick up a camera but what is
their lasting legacy for spielberg it's
a versatile artist who's touched when it
comes to storytelling knows no bounds he
can go big with dinosaurs small with spy
bridges and even tell a story about
three people coming together that feels
like a big summer blockbuster shark
movie in fact steven has also referred
to himself as a director without a style
he simply shows up to serve the story
that he's tasked with telling look at
how he uses quiet human moments in a
film like the color purple to emphasize
heartbreak and resolve then check out
indiana jones in the last crusade when
we open on a young indie having the time
of his life running around with
coronado's cross yet for spielberg
sometimes when he references his own
chameleon-like ability it feels like
he's lamenting the fact that he doesn't
have a signature style like say a martin
scorsese marty clearly has a sandbox he
loves the plan and it's much more than
just flawed humans that broke bad and
got an extreme close-up it's his kinetic
energy that he utilizes to tell the
tales that reflect our own demons travis
bickle's iconic you talking to me moment
or rupert pumpkin's misguided attempt at
a monologue shows us that folks may be
born with a screw loose but it's our
society that shaped them into the
potential monsters that they could turn
out to be a great scorsese quote about
filmmaking are you writing this down
kids cinema is a matter of what's in the
frame and what's out and what's inside
his wheelhouse as an auteur is the
frequent use of narration to fill us in
on the action and the guy who loves a
good montage set to rock music it's so
fun to see this master craftsman in the
opening moments of shine away the
concert film he directed with the
rolling stones because mick jagger will
not give him the set list until right
before the show and marty is all
frazzled all these great tunes he's used
in his movies over decades and now he's
at the mercy of the band that created
many of those masterpieces it's fun
story time with uncle mark scorsese
showed up on set once while his buddy
stephen was making a movie called catch
me if you can now marty was no doubt
keeping an eye on young leo and possibly
said something along the lines of hey
kid are you uh busy for the next 20
years then during production for wolf of
wall street the next decade guess who
rolled up steven spielberg never one to
sit idly by steve offered some tips and
advice during a day when a few of jordan
belfort's legendary speeches were being
shot can you imagine being dicaprio you
do a take you go to get notes and then
you see scorsese and spielberg sitting
together that's chess pounding stuff as
in mcconaughey
look you're getting something at least
good and probably great with either one
of these fellas so how do you choose do
you go with the film buff whose hugo is
so well made that it stands as a fun
family adventure and an amazingly
detailed retelling of the very origins
of talking pictures or you take the guy
who's made multiple films in every
section of blockbuster video that still
exists in bend oregon for me i love all
kinds of films and in my old age i tend
to lean towards the smaller pictures
versus the huge comic book theme park
movies but every so often i do need
those big event tent poles that are a
great excuse to shove popcorn into my
face steven spielberg isn't a director
without a style he's a genius who can
mold his technique to serve any story no
matter how big small or intergalactic
i've probably re-watched scorsese movies
more than any other film catalog not
named star wars but for pure versatility
enthusiasm and panache i'm giving the
win here to mr steven spielberg congrats
now you know what prove me right go make
a problem child sequel i'm sure it'll be
fresh and that's how we do it here at
versus they always start out fun they're
celebrations we're talking about high
art and then i get stressed and have to
make a decision that you the home viewer
will probably make me think twice about
i took steven over martin today i also
love steve martin but now it's your turn
my friends vote with your social media
handle and hit me up at mark ellis live
with your take thanks for watching this
edition of versus and speaking of
directors this was directed by the great
val give her a hand everyone and it
starred me who i'm told is the harrison
ford nope
no i'm not all right since spielberg won
i'll close up shop here with one of the
more memorable lines from jurassic park
this is versus i'm mark ellis and thanks
for holding on to my butt
no no
oh okay i got it thanks for watching
versus i'm mark ellis and this has been
one big pile of no that's not the ticket
you know what screw it i'm mark ellis
and as far back as i can remember i
always wanted to be a gangster
you